parce que pour la première fois au
Québec il y a éclosion d'un champignon
potentiellement mortel le candidat Auris
il a été détecté au début du mois à
l'hôpital Pierre Boucher à Longueuil
deux patients sont infectés trois autres
cas possibles sont à l'étude une cellule
de crise nationale a été mobilisée j'en
parle avec le docteur jasmin Villeneuve
il est médecin conseil à l'Institut
national de santé publique du Québec
docteur Villeneuve bonsoir
alors on entendait de vos confrères se
montrer inquiet est-ce que vous l'êtes
vous par cette éclosion dans un hôpital
en fait on est toujours préoccupé quand
il arrive une éclosion avec un pathogène
nouveau que l'on connaît pas pour être
sûr que les mesures sont en place et
connaître la situation mais on n'est pas
inquiet autre mesure actuellement mais
vous dites que c'est un pathogène
nouveau en fait relativement nouveau
n'est-ce pas
en fait il est nouveau au Québec où on a
eu quelques cas antérieurement dans les
années antérieures c'est la première
éclosion rapportée au Québec c'est un
agent pathogène qui a été identifié
depuis 2009 en Asie qui s'est répandu
dans différents pays du monde entre
autres aux États-Unis actuellement il
est en augmentation donc il est
relativement nouveau dans certains
endroits plus de plus historiques où il
est installé plus dans d'autres milieux
mais pour le Québec il est quand même
nouveau bon cela dit ces circonscrits
Pierre Boucher est-ce que c'est
dangereux en ce moment pour le personnel
de l'hôpital où les autres patients
faut savoir que c'est un champignon qui
va être dangereux ou qui va causer des
infections surtout chez les patients qui
sont déjà très immunos supprimés qui ont
des maladies chroniques multiples qui
sont beaucoup plus à risque de
développer une infection ou de rester
porteur du champignon à long terme pour
les personnes en bonne santé pour le
personnel ou les gens qui fréquentent
l’hôpital il y a pas de danger
actuellement à travailler ou à
fréquenter l'hôpital actuellement malgré
les closons en cours c'est parce qu'on a
lu des choses apparemment il est apparu
dans l’hôpital du Mont sinaïier à New
York et que on avait beaucoup de mal à
décontaminer la chambre bien fait qu'on
change des pans de mur entier qu'est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on a fait à
Pierre Boucher qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire en présence de ce champignon
ce qu'on connaît de ce champignon c'est
qu'il peut avoir tendance effectivement
à contaminer l'environnement on doit
donc appliquer des mesures de prévention
de désinfection régulière avec les bons
produits c'est un peu comme quand on
s'occupe d'un c'est difficile on a
besoin de produits chlorés ou de
paroxysme d'hydrogène c'est les mêmes
produits qu'on va utiliser il peut
arriver dans un milieu je connais pas la
situation du Mont sinaïe il y a des fois
des milieux ou les murs ou les planchers
sont brisés sont très difficiles à
désinfecter et à ce moment-là la
meilleure façon c'est de faire un
changement des structures des
infrastructures sont en place mais c'est
pas de façon courante qu'on a besoin de
changer tout l'environnement pour
apprendre le contrôle donc je comprends
qu'il se propage en restant sur les
surfaces des différents objets par
contact corporel aussi par l'air ce qui
dit est-ce que les sports c'est un
champignon après tout ce qui peut être
dans l'air je pose des questions
en fait ça fait partie de la classe des
champignons mais c'est plus une levure
donc il ne va pas faire les sports de la
même façon que d'autres champignons ils
ne se propagent pas par là c'est
vraiment par contact contact direct ou à
peau avec une personne contact indirecte
avec l'environnement les appareils
utilisés et il peut rester effectivement
dans l'environnement si on effectue pas
de désinfection quand on effectue des
infections régulières et adéquates on
peut arriver à le contrôler bon alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on dit c'est un
champignon on voit qu'il est quand même
pas mal contagieux pourquoi est-ce qu'il
est mortel potentiellement mortelle
en fait c'est un champignon qui se
démarque de l'ensemble des champignons
de des autres familles les autres genres
de candidats qu'on connaît où il va se
transmettre plus facilement d'une
personne à l'autre alors que les autres
candidats se transmettent moins il peut
donner des infections invasives chez les
personnes à risque que je parlais tantôt
des immunos supprimés ou des personnes
qui ont des maladies chroniques et ces
infections évasives pourrait amener au
décès mais c'est des gens qui ont déjà
beaucoup de pathologies qui vont être
beaucoup plus fragiles pour les
infections et quand vous êtes invisible
vous voulez dire que c'est tout le corps
ça serait systémique versus un coin de
un membre par exemple exactement quand
on parle d'invasir si ça va être de soit
un organe interne ou dans le sang va se
promener dans le sang qui va donner une
infection quand même très sévère c'est
un organisme qui a aussi des résistances
au traitement donc il peut être très
difficile à traiter avec les traitements
classiques c'est pas toutes les souches
de candidoris qui ont les mêmes types de
résistance mais il peut présenter des
difficultés à être traitées ce qui fait
que ça augmente encore probabilité ou la
possibilité de donner des infections
sévères qui peuvent mener au décès et
c'est ce qu'on a vu au travers le monde
il y a eu quand même beaucoup de décès
mais j'ai des personnes qui étaient déjà
très très malades mais j'ai lu quelque
part que le risque d'en mourir de cette
infection atteignait 60% c'est ça
ça va dépendre c'est sûr que faut
regarder selon les études selon les
situations et souvent ce qu'on voit pas
c'est est-ce que la personne est décédée
de l'infection parce que c'est un
candidatrice où elle est décédée parce
qu'elle a une infection parce qu'elle
était déjà très malade c'est pas
toujours évident de faire la peur des
choses où est la cause de qu'est-ce qui
a fait décéder la personne bon je pense
qu'aux États-Unis c'est déjà été déclaré
comme endémique là c'est quand même
assez courant
on en trouve ça dans les hôpitaux vous
disiez des gens riminaux supprimés très
malades on a vu des cas aussi ici au
pays beaucoup plus rare mais c'était
tous chez des patients qui revenaient de
l'étranger mais pas à Pierre Boucher
alors comment expliquer cette nouvelle
contamination ici
actuellement au Québec on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il est endémique ou
qu'il est présent dans l'environnement
ou dans la population c'est
effectivement les situations qu'on a eu
comme là comme vous dites la majorité
des cas au Canada c'était des gens qui
l'avaient importé d'ailleurs
actuellement ce qui est possible
l'hypothèse c'est quelqu'un est arrivé
avec ne pas été détecté aurait pu donner
des secondaires ce qu'on vient de
trouver à Pierre Boucher c'est l'enquête
qui va déterminer justement est-ce que
c'est la bonne hypothèse et d'où ça peut
provenir et c'est la meilleure hypothèse
qu'on a actuellement parce que on en a
pas d'autres on en a pas dans la
population on en a pas dans les
communautés donc on pense pas que ça
vient du Québec mais c'est arrivé
d'ailleurs et on l'a pas détecté avant
les patients dont on parle actuellement
en terminant à ce qu'on peut supposer
que on en aura de plus en plus de
contaminations avec ce candidat aurait
mais comme tout agent en émergence c'est
possible effectivement d'en avoir plus
et pourquoi on s'est préparé déjà
d'avance avant même la pandémie de covid
on avait préparé des recommandations des
lignes directrices pour faire face à
l'éventuelle thé d'un cas les hôpitaux
dans l'hôpital Pierre Boucher ont
appliqué les mesures en conséquence et
bien sûr on va se préparer le fait d'en
avoir eu fait qu'on peut en avoir
d'autres entre autres on parlait des
États-Unis où il y a plus de code donc
c'est une possibilité oui qu'on en est
donc docteur Villeneuve merci beaucoup
au revoir merci à vous au revoir